au nom du peuple français le premier
conseil de guerre du gouvernement
militaire de paris a reconnu le nommer
dreyfus alfred coupables du crime de
haute trahison
la leçon à tirer du châtiment ne dreyfus
est de montrer au monde ce que nous
faisons des traîtres vous êtes désormais
responsable du renseignement
si nous découvrons que dreyfus et pas de
traîtres
je pense que nous devrions agir
rapidement dans l'intérêt de l'armée bon
dieu mon colonel de 7 ans b 3e du chef
ou souvent leur sort que je ne veux pas
d'une autre refusent ce n'est pas une
autre affaire dreyfus en général
c'est la même
will dossiers secrets sur fréjus
désormais s'en charge aurait
personnellement on intercepte mon
courrier je suis constamment suivi le
tue prouver tout cela voudrait éviter un
scandale c'est déjà un scandale
j'ai quitté paris quelque temps et toi
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter
monsieur emile zola quelqu'un doit
exposer toute l'histoire pour tant
qu'officier d'actifs je ne peux rien
écrire là dessus vous non
mais moi aussi j'accuse le général
mercier de s'être rendue complice d'une
des plus grande dignité du siècle
je refuse que génération d'avoir usé
trajet d'une agence de presse us de les
avoir étouffés
j'accuse les experts en écriture devra
fait des rapports frauduleux
traître
quand une société on est là
elle tombe en décomposition
[Musique]